but right now we begin this hour with
our exclusive conversation with former
president Barack Obama since leaving
office the 44th president has used his
influence and resources to help some of
those who need it most the Obama's
Foundation My Brother's Keeper Alliance
was designed to fill opportunity gaps
for young men of color the group
recently announced it will focus on four
model communities that have shown that
success in those areas they are Newark
New Jersey Omaha Nebraska Tulsa Oklahoma
and Yonkers New York we spent a few days
with Obama in Chicago where we saw
firsthand the impact he and his
foundation are having on communities
it's never safe no matter where you go
you got hustles popping four fives
instead of six votes on the basement of
this Baptist Church on Chicago's South
Side they're working on a lot more than
music
who was that that was Ricky that
violence May Inspire some of their
lyrics but this safe space is about
personal connections feeling seen and
heard
[Music]
guitars over guns it's a Grassroots
program that gives teens a chance to
work on their lyrics beats and
production skills are you trying to do
some upbeat can we do something
storytelling we're gonna talk about
what's going on in the world and mentors
to help remind them of their potential
story of a young man and to make it out
gave his whole life to the game even
when he had his doubts it's one of many
programs the Obama foundation and it's
my brother's keeper initiative help
support and that's what my brother's
keeper is all about helping more of our
young people stay on track providing the
support they need to think more broadly
about their future when nearly a decade
later some of that progress was shared
on this stage in downtown Chicago
what's going on man whether former
president of the United States gathered
Community leaders from around the
country specifically Newark Omaha Tulsa
and Yonkers New York highlighting what
is working in education and violence
prevention in those places Newark mayor
Raz Baraka we were able to experience 35
reduction last year just in shooting
victims uh alone which is historic for
us we want to talk to you with Resources
with job opportunities with educational
opportunities with love alternative
that's right with love not just
handcuffs right 200 cities with varying
degrees of success are making the effort
to identify the barriers and knock those
barriers away for so many of our young
boys and young men of color so that they
can succeed making sure they're prepared
for school making sure that there's a
job waiting for them if they do the
right thing and then dealing with
violence in their communities the vast
majority of these young people will
succeed and that will be good for all of
us gun violence is the number one cause
of death for children in this country
what is the radical solution and do you
believe there is a larger issue at hand
that causes fractures Among Us in this
country we are unique
among advanced
developed Nations
in tolerating
on a routine basis gun violence in the
form of shootings
mass shootings
suicides you know in Australia he had
one mass shooting
50 years ago and they said oh we're not
doing that anymore that is normally how
you would expect a society to respond
when your children are at risk why is it
so hard for us well look I think somehow
and and there are a lot of historical
reasons for this
uh gun ownership in this country
became a ideological issue and a
partisan issue in ways that it shouldn't
be
it has become sort of a proxy for
arguments about our culture wars instead
of thinking about it in a very pragmatic
way we end up really arguing about
identity and emotion and all kinds of
stuff that does not have to do with
keeping our children safe even in the
absence of action at the federal level
you are still seeing communities
able to reduce Violence by dealing with
not just access to guns but just as
importantly making sure that the young
people in these communities feel as if
they've got somebody who's paying
attention to them we don't have room for
cynicism and and we can't give up
no cynicism
at Dropbox
[Music]
truthfully I'm contemplates at making
only fans my only fans will probably
look at me like are you crazy man but
I'm just trying to make some mess and
maybe help my mama see Jamaica man talk
to Poverty like see you later man
maybe a couple you just tell me a little
bit about how you came to know about the
program
uh why it's been important to you the
kinds of things that you've been doing
go ahead I've been coming from Lake
Geneva I think it was he ended up
inviting to the studio okay and when I
came in it was a day that I didn't have
school and he thought that I was
suspended for school so he wouldn't let
me record music until he got the
approval okay
you can sit over here and do your work
you know you can chill in the studio all
day but you got to definitely uh I got
to get an approval first and I got we
got the approve I was able to record
okay all right I've been since then
fantastic seeing the former president of
the United States walk in here and show
how much he's invested not just in what
you guys are doing here but also this
community
what did that mean to you I want to just
kind of show you somebody kiss or it's
like it's easier to reach you know it's
like it's not like you just speaking to
the community or you just like you know
just showing your face to the community
on camera and so for him to come in and
Shake everybody hand you know listen to
the raps actually give feedback it kind
of meant a lot hey this praying for my
stress hope in doubt I'll break the
sweat Evo King's my source so I'm
passing every single test when we went
to that program and you saw this
incredible talent in a church basement
making music and Nate I I think you felt
it too what was most powerful about it
was seeing these young men really
looking out for each other
getting more of that yeah in our
communities is also going to make a
difference and and that's what we're
demonstrating through these model
communities of My Brother's Keeper it's
a matter of want to on the part of the
broader Society you know I'm a father of
a 19 year old
17 year old a 12 year old and I am an
optimistic man
but I find myself falling into this
space where I have concern about the
country that they will inherit right
once I'm gone
post-presidency what about this country
keeps you up at night the thing that I'm
most worried about is
the degree to which
we now have a divided conversation
in part because we have a divided media
right so
I'm much older than you Nate
you don't look it though that's what I
was fishing for
but when I was coming up you had three
TV stations yeah and people were getting
a similar sense of what is true and what
isn't what was real and what was not
today what I'm most concerned about is
the fact that because of the splintering
of the media we almost occupy different
realities if something happens in the
past everybody could say all right we
may disagree on how to solve it but at
least we all agree that yeah that's an
issue now people will say well that
didn't happen or I don't believe that
and one of I think the goals of the
Obama foundation and and one of the
goals of my post-presidency is how do we
return to that common conversation how
can we have a common set of facts we may
disagree on gun violence in terms of
what the best prescriptions are
but we can't deny the data that says the
United States has levels of gun violence
that are 5 10 15 times more than other
countries so if we say that it's just a
mental health problem well it's not like
there aren't people with mental health
problems in those other countries what's
the difference right this is probably
the difference now we can have a debate
but at least we've agreed on some uh
some facts
wow you know I I thoroughly enjoyed the
conversation
um specifically the part when he talked
about
media being fractured yeah and how we
now occupy different realities so
there's rarely common ground that we
find as a country when it comes to
issues that are ripping us apart and
working in media it gave me a different
perspective on what we do and and it
also allows me to look in the mirror how
well are we doing the job of making sure
that both sides of whatever Spectrum can
at least see truth and then start a
conversation after that well that's the
thing I've never heard it put that way a
divided conversation he didn't even use
the phrase divided country right use
divided conversation that I've never
heard it put that way and I think it's
he's so on point about that that's
what's so scary that we can't even agree
on the facts anymore and how do you get
back to that I still don't know I also
like what he said about guns that we
tolerate on a routine basis children
getting killed we tolerate that yeah
it's it's heartbreaking to me it's so
important to remind ourselves that the
goal here might find Hope and I know
yours as well is that this table here
will be that common conversation in
American life and you can have
conversations like that he's also you
know he's quite an academic he's a deep
reader he's historically correct in
saying that the gun debate has become
ideological I mean as recently as the
late 80s the Republican Supreme Court
nominees did not interpret the Second
Amendment as meaning individual
ownership of firearms but State militias
yeah it's been a cultural and a legal
shift in interpretation and and that
means that we can go back to it in
theory no I've heard people say when it
comes to Barack Obama you may you never
questioned his character his integrity
and his intelligence and I think that
was just another example there I thought
that was such a great conversation on
many different topics and let me further
clarify what YouTube just touched on he
wasn't dismissive of mental health he
was not um and in fact he went on to say
there's other countries that deal with
mental health like we do yep we just
tolerate gun violence at a higher level
we do that
that was really good Nate really good
Bravo to the team that was involved in
Barack Obama's team of course Bravo